jedes wochenende das gleiche spiel
seit nunmehr fünf jahren trakt orchester
auf dem weg zum konzert mit einem haufen
blech an bord auch mit durchaus exotisch
ob es am alten feuerwehr bus liegt oder
am kassel ein leicht nostalgischer wind
weht einem um die ohren wenn man mit der
charmanten kapelle auf tour ist
man fühlt sich ein wenig wie auf
schulreise auch selbst organisierte
hinter trakt orchester steckt viel
eigenes engagement
sie haben nicht mal einen manager machen
und da ist es dieses reißen
diese sehnsucht nach fremden ländern es
ist das fernweh wie es hier auf dem
neuen trakt orchester album von
gastsängerin steff la cheffe besungen
wird
das konzert heute in schaffhausen ist
eines der ersten mit dem neuen album
balkan brass nennt man diese serbische
blasmusik die so gefühlsduselig ist dass
die berner ihr auf ewig verfallen sind
musik voller melancholie fast triefendem
herz weh bittersüßem weltschmerz
es ist einfach melodie einer moto2
ständig gesperrt
und dann wird's getragen
es ist mir die zweite studie stützt die
erste untersuchung und und mit mehr
aufmerksamkeit
der emotionale und hingen aber die
ganzen bunten und es ist glatt und
kombination
es ist eine virtuose fast schon
archaisch urgewalt die einen hier
überrollt das blech shepherd die
tanzbeine zappeln das publikum haben die
zwölf ausgebildeten jazzmusiker spielend
im griff
zu beginn ihrer bandgeschichte spielten
trakt orchester hauptsächlich zwischen
uns sie imitierten überlieferte
volksmusik auch heute übernimmt gaststar
orange mit run den traditionellen fahrt
des konzerns
ein großteil der neuen stücke sind aber
mittlerweile eigenkompositionen gemischt
mit einflüssen aus der schweizer
volksmusik
und wenn sie am schluss ihre version vom
vreneli am kiesberg spielen dann spüren
wir es wieder dieses sehnsüchtige reißen
dieses heimweh nach fernen ländern